so i'm going to begin by telling you a
story
okay uh here's the story last year my
best friend got married
uh and so i was his best man and yeah it
was it was fun he was my best man
um so he's kind of like returning to it
would have been really
awful if it's like i made him my best
man and then like
you know however many years later it's
like you're sorry man that would be
really dope anyway
so either out of guilt or because he
really thought i was a good friend of
his he may be best man now i
am i don't really like spend a lot of
money on clothing you can probably tell
that but anyway
um i've never um like gone and got a
suit tailored
before okay because it's super expensive
and it probably made
but because i was the best man and we
were both having like matching stuff etc
um got it tailored right so i go into
the place can't remember what it's
called
um and there's a lady there and she's
like okay
um to make sure that this is gonna fit
you i have to take some measurements
okay
and it's a full like it's it's you know
everything really uh
there's there was trousers um there was
the
shirt the vest uh special tie and then
the
the actual blazer suit part right okay
so all these different bits
i don't know because i was the best man
so i didn't have to pay for it
i assumed it was just rental so it
shouldn't have been that much but anyway
so so i go there and she's like okay um
she gets her what's it called like a
tape measure
measuring tape thing right she gets it
out and um
she says okay just stand still right i
can't no problem so she
she puts it around my neck and she like
writes down a number
and then she's like okay hold out your
hand so i hold up my hand and she like
takes down her number
and then she she puts it against like
from my ankle to like my hip or
something
and she takes a number and she does one
or two other things but it's super fast
and she's like okay i'm done
and i'm like wait hold on like that only
took like 30 seconds you only got i
looked at a piece of paper it's like
four numbers
written on it and i'm like surely you
cannot boil me down
to just four numbers like don't you like
there's all these different things
that you need all these things that need
to fit there's all kinds of measurements
like my arm length and my
waist and my on and on and on that she
didn't take right and i said
don't you kind of need more information
that you've written down and she's like
no
i've got it all right and i'm like
really so disbelieving
she said don't worry i'll be right back
so she sat down i sat down
she went away to like the back room or
something like that
and then came out with all of the pieces
of clothing right and i was
honestly a bit skeptical okay i'm super
thin so most things don't fit me
nicely like cause i'm the wrong
proportions and all that
um but she brought it back and she's
like okay try this on something
well you know i better give it a go so
it went
changed and to my shock and surprise
every single item fit perfectly
down to like even when um when i was at
school
this just tells you what asians are like
um all of my clothes were too large
because you know you buy them
like so they last you for a long time
right so i couldn't to read my watch
right
my sleeves are too long so i'd have to
do this maneuver to try and get my hand
out i'd be like ah
and then like oh i got my watch there
right and i was like i was really cool i
had this
tailored thing on and i was like oh i
could see my watch i was so
impressed and it fit nice and
comfortably and the length was all
sweet and i was like wow okay fine
i take back you know i was wrong just
like four or five numbers
and it's all you need to know okay now
question for you
how does that work how can so few
numbers
help you or a tailor to completely
outfit a person and
nothing else how does that work
hmm let's just take an example i'm like
okay i think she did take my armory okay
but she didn't take like
like this length here um and she didn't
take my like she didn't take
this length it's just halfway um she
didn't take you know
this this uh width around here but it
still fit perfectly
how did it all work how did it fit
together
i take it i just give you a simple
example if you know how long my whole
arm is
right it's like well you know
this part of my arm from my elbow to my
wrist it's pretty much going to be half
that length right maybe slightly off
but pretty much right uh in terms of
like the the
diameter circumference sorry of my wrist
it's also
pretty closely connected all of the
numbers sort of fit together
if you know these few numbers you can
define the whole
person in the whole body right
trigonometry is the same idea
but it's not for people it's for um
it's for trigons what's a trigon
you guys actually know what a trigon is
there's a more familiar word that you
guys know
um which is a polygon what's a polygon
what does poly means like um
like poly poly unsaturated fats or
polymers uh poly means many poly means
many
not double l single l um
and and gone means angle so this means
any shape with lots of angles in it
right polygons so therefore a trigon is
something with
three angles right which we we call them
triangles don't we
okay um and metro that comes from that's
the same word for like meter
and metric it's about measurement okay
so just like the taylor
right was measuring me we're going to be
doing a lot of
measurement of triangles that's what
this is uh try
that's what this topic really means it's
just that triangle measurement
is kind of a mouthful so they kind of
boil it down a little bit
okay so the idea is that you can know
very very few
things about a triangle maybe an angle
maybe a couple sides you don't have to
know everything
and you can work out everything else
from there right just like you can work
out
behind and next circumference blah
okay